hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll we
talk a lot about physics on the show and
if you asked people on the street what
physics studies you might hear something
about matter and energy moving through
space and time or space time if they had
been introduced to relativity just a
little bit
modern quantum mechanics and gravity are
coming together to suggest that this
space-time idea is not as fundamental as
we thought the reason why you think it's
so fundamental there's many reasons but
one is that things interact with each
other when they bump into each other at
the same point in space this is
basically locality that's a crude way of
putting it but the same thing is true
for a field Theory like a Quantum field
Theory like the standard model of
particle physics if you poke the quantum
Fields the field reacts at that point in
space and immediately nearby it doesn't
react instantly very very far away there
can be interactions that Ripple out at
the speed of light or slower but that's
within space that's where locality comes
from
now you make a black hole you quantize
the quantum feels around that black hole
Stephen Hawking says the black hole
radiates and we get the black hole
information loss puzzle if you throw a
book or some other piece of information
into a black hole how does it get out in
the radiation still don't know the
answer to that we've had some ideas
we've had a podcast about it with
another engelhardt not too long ago
but along the way we've learned some
very interesting things like if you
think the information does get out which
you have very good reason to think then
there's something non-local going on
about the black hole there is something
as if the information of the black hole
is distributed around its Horizon its
boundary its two-dimensional surface
rather than distributed within the
three-dimensional volume of the black
hole and this idea was eventually
developed in what we call the
holographic principle by gerarditov and
Leonard's huskind among others Lenin
suskin of course being a previous
mindscape guest we are still struggling
to understand what the holographic
principle precisely says and how to
precisely formulate it as well as what
it implies for a new generation of
physics where locality is not Central so
today's guest is Rafael buso who is a
physicist at UC Berkeley and one of the
big names in holography and black call
information I remember when I was a
postdoc we had the first intimations of
holography within the context of black
holes but Leonard tuskind and Willie
Fishler actually wrote a paper where
they tried to generalize it to more
General circumstances and I instantly
recognized that there were flaws in
their ways of doing it they sort of
assumed some things that weren't always
true Etc and I thought to myself you
know someone should do this right maybe
I should do it right but I was doing
other things didn't pay attention to it
and then very soon thereafter came a
paper by Raphael that I read and I
remember thinking I'm glad I didn't try
to do this because this is much better
job than I would have done at this and
uh Raphael became a star after that and
has been since then still pushing our
understanding forward on black holes the
nature of space-time the Multiverse the
holography black hole complementarity
all these different kinds of things and
he's a very articulate explainer of
these ideas the whole field is still
very much moving we don't have the final
answers yet so I think you'll get some
of the impression of that in this
conversation there's great ideas coming
out here we don't yet know how they all
fit together so like I always like to do
for the young people out there this is
important stuff that you could think
about and make a contribution to uh
we're still learning that's the exciting
fun place to be so occasional reminder
that we have a patreon for the mindscape
podcast uh go to patreon.com Sean M
Carol if you want to get sign up for
some number of dollars including one for
each podcast episode you get an ad free
version and you get the right to ask
questions for the monthly ask me
anything episodes uh and it's fun you
get a sense of accomplishment and
Community things like that so with that
let's go
[Music]
thank you
Rafael Busa welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks for having me Sean I
thought that we would start because a
lot of people I bet in the audience like
they've certainly heard about quantum
gravity I've talked about it they
certainly heard about string deer you
had a couple string theorists on we've
even heard about Loop quantum gravity uh
but maybe there's some
stage setting to be done about like how
do you personally think about the
relationship of gravity general
relativity quantum gravity as a field
String Theory as some sort of specific
version of that oh good
um
I I guess I started out going into
physics just sort of vaguely wanting to
know about fundamental stuff you know I
was fascinated by what I'd learned uh
glimpsed in high school maybe about you
know quantum mechanics and and special
relativity
um and and about the fact that nature
behaves in ways that are so hard for us
to guess because they're so hard so far
away from our everyday experience and
that at the same time you're sort of
forced to these conclusions and it just
seemed like this was something I wanted
to learn more about and and so then of
course I learned fairly soon that it's
it's sort of those two big developments
of the early 20th century
um that we haven't managed to fit
together yet there was this one track of
of Einstein discovering uh special and
general relativity which is the theory
of how space and time are structured on
large scales and you know it tells you
things like that you can't go faster
than the speed of light uh it tells you
that that gravity is really the response
of space and time to the presence of
matter bending it in some ways and
things trying to go as straight as they
can in that warped world
and in itself that was a huge success
it's very well tested it describes how
the planets move and how the universe
expands
um
but then there was a second track where
people uh began to understand the atomic
and subatomic World
um through through this idea of quantum
mechanics and if you thought that warp
space-time was crazy that stuff is
really crazy I don't think quantum
mechanics could have ever been
discovered the way that Einstein did
discover his stuff by just kind of
thinking abstractly about some
contradictions between theories that he
knew about and trying to resolve them
quantum mechanics is so crazy that it
had to be discovered by you know
experiments Atomic Spectra the fact that
matter when it's warm doesn't emit an
infinite amount of energy it turns out
to be a surprising thing stuff like that
you had to have experimental data
dragging you kicking and screaming to
this crazy Theory which says that you
know systems can be in two states at
once you can add a cat and an alive cat
a debt in a life cat excuse me uh
together and crazy stuff like that so so
those were both huge successes because
also quantum mechanics explained how
atoms work it explained it eventually
led to our uh theory of Elementary
particles all all the known subatomic
forces uh are very well explained by it
um and yet and yet we don't know how to
fit those two strands together
and that's what quantum gravity is about
and you know when you think about how
exciting the conceptual advances were
that came with discovering that the
universe is expanding that space and
time are warped or with discovering
these crazy aspects of quantum mechanics
you can only wonder how
how much more dramatic it must be to
understand how those two things fit
together I think that'll be another huge
step and it'll allow us to think about
the universe in in completely new ways
but as always in physics important those
are not random ways those are going to
be ways which are dictated by
consistency with all the experiments
that have been done
um and I can't wait to find out what
they are do you think we're close do you
think quantum gravity is uh In Our
Lifetime let's say as young vigorous
people that could be a long time I
understand but um
yeah I I you know I wonder I mean
there's there's a pessimist view where
we'll you know we'll never quite get
there you know whenever we we discover a
new Theory it's going to be richer it's
going to explain more things with fewer
ingredients
um but it's not quite you know it's
gonna pose new questions that are going
to lead us to the next Frontier
um I don't know if maybe that's actually
not pessimistic because that'll keep all
generations happy and busy
um but that you know that I think that's
a possibility but I think there are also
um you know reasonable arguments that
could be made that this might be it that
if you figure out how to how to put
together gravity with quantum mechanics
um then at least on the well on that
front of trying to understand nature
fundamentally you would be done there
would still be a lot of other things to
do uh like understand the consequences
of such a theory and you know I I don't
think we'll ever be able to describe the
behavior of a zebra using fundamental
physics so there's also other beautiful
Sciences but it's it's it might be the
end now whether we'll get there in my
lifetime I have absolutely no idea
um because I could be run over by a
truck tomorrow but
um but you know I think I think we'll
yeah I think we'll learn many
interesting things in the decades to
come and I'm particularly excited about
the the time that we're in right now
actually and do you think of string
theory as the leading current candidate
uh to be quantum gravity
String Theory I think is
um has given us from my perspective as
far as I can tell the only consistent
candidate for theories of quantum
gravity that are in any sense complete
in particular it has led to the
discovery of the adsc FD correspondence
that is a lot of letters but what it
means is that there's a certain class of
universes unfortunately not including
the one that we seem to be living in but
still a very rich
uh set of you know space times worlds
that you can imagine
um which for which we have a complete
quantum theory of gravity or at least I
mean it could be it could be wrong we
haven't you know tested it
experimentally but it's it's a very
significant statement that you have a
theory which is complete in itself it's
not missing anything you could put it on
a computer and run it you can calculate
things with it
um and and so that I would say is from
from the physics perspective the the
number one
um thing that has come out of string
theory there's a lot of beautiful
mathematical results and many other
applications uh that the theory has had
another
um important consequence of string
theory is that you would expect that the
kind of world that we see around us the
kind of particles and forces that we see
um are no more unique than you know the
kind of atoms that there are there's or
molecules you know there's water there's
air there's different things you can
build out of the fundamental ingredients
and string theory suggests to us that
the so-called fundamental particles that
we see might actually really be
um
things that were put together from even
more fundamental ingredients that exist
in string theory and that could have
been put together in different ways and
probably in some Far Away parts of the
universe that we can't see it are put
together in different ways and that
helps us explain a few things
um or it gives us a chance to explain a
few things that are puzzling about our
universe for example how it got to be so
old and and large
um so so String Theory certainly had a
huge number of successes what what we
haven't done yet
is get to it from String Theory sort of
fell into our Labs it it was a
theoretical structure that just seems to
be you know very rigid very rich uh you
can't dial a whole lot of things about
it and
um and you know we don't have a whole
lot of other very explicit ways of doing
quantum mechanics and gravity at the
same time uh it was not discovered in
the way that we usually make discoveries
in physics either by some experimental
data or by some you know how did
Einstein make his discoveries he he
understood that there was a conflict
between otherwise successful theories of
physics Newtonian mechanics let's say
and and Maxwell's theory of electricity
and magnetism they they were very
successful but at some sort of
fundamental level they were completely
in conflict with each other and so he
thought about for a while and he decided
here are the fundamental principles that
need to
um that that need to underlie a
unification of this the space-time
structure has to be that of
electromagnetism he decided and then he
adapted Newtonian mechanics to fit that
and this sort of way where you start
with what you already know and you
identify some guiding principle and then
try to construct a new bigger better
Theory from that that's not how we
discovered String Theory but that's
something that we're also trying to do
when we do quantum gravity so there's
sort of two ends from which we're trying
to bore the tunnel if you will uh so
that second end we think about what
could be guiding principles that tell us
how to put together a theory that that
that allows both of these structures to
live under one roof and to sort of
emerge from from you know a more unified
picture and and that's actually what I'm
mostly busy doing right now that's
that's an area of physics where there's
a lot of progress right now but I guess
I would say or at least um I mean I'll
let you put into your own words but what
I want to get across to the audience is
the idea that people like you I would
say work on quantum gravity in a way
that is string theory adjacent String
Theory compatible but you're not
calculating a lot of string Loop
diagrams or maybe even really being
beholden to the specific structures of
string theory hands down to you there's
still sort of quantum gravity as a field
in addition to string theory as a field
even though there's a lot of overlap
between them is that how you would think
of it no I would not I think that's
um that's I I I think as much as so I I
want to say this without diminishing
string theory in any way but the kind of
progress that we're making right now
could have in principle happened
entirely without knowing anything about
string theory right uh so I think that's
what I was trying to say sorry maybe I
didn't say yeah eloquently I'm trying to
say that you and your friends are doing
quantum gravity in a way that is not in
opposition to string theory but is also
not built upon String Theory yeah now
for historical reasons String Theory
does exist and it's given us very
powerful tools yeah and those tools have
played in practice a huge role in
allowing
the kind of progress that I'm excited
about in recent years to happen so in
particular this ads UFT correspondence
that I mentioned earlier
um has in convoluted ways to some extent
led us to understand something about how
gravity itself knows a lot more about
quantum mechanics then we're giving it
credit for this is something that's not
true for any other classical Theory uh
electromagnetism Maxwell's classical
Theory doesn't know in any reasonable
sense anything about the additional
features that Quantum electrodynamics
that it's it's so-called quantization
brings to the table there's there's no
way you could have extracted that from
the classical Theory
um but gravity Einstein's theory
bizarrely
knows something about its own Quantum
States and actually the quantum states
of all the matter fields and and forces
that exist in nature
and that's a really fascinating and
bizarre property which you know we've
sort of seen glimpses off over the last
four or five decades in a bunch of
places for example when when uh
beckenstein and Hawking discovered how
many Quantum States a black hole has
that's something that you should have no
right of figure to figure out until you
have an actual quantum theory that tells
you what the individual states are
you know it's like asking how many
states does a block of metal have and
you don't have any idea that it's made
out of atoms
um there's no way that you could know
the answer to that but gravity has sort
of tricky backdoor ways of letting you
figure that out if you ask nicely and
we've recently understood how to ask a
lot of new questions a lot of more
sophisticated questions nicely and
getting gravity to answer them for us
and
um in practice the way that this was
discovered had a lot to do with with
earlier breakthroughs in string theory
but as a matter of principle the the
properties that gravity has that allow
you to do this are independent and and
you know maybe in on some other planet
they're discovering that before they
discovered String Theory I don't know
this is very very good I I like this
perspective I've sort of heard it before
but but I think you articulated it very
clearly is it too much to say that this
is kind of a culmination of
Einstein's insights into the principle
of equivalence when you know when he
says that gravity is like the other
forces in some ways but it's also
different in some ways it's more
Universal uh you know there's there's
not different electrical charges to go
different directions so gravity touches
everything the same way therefore it's
the curvature of space-time is it is it
too crazy to say gravity is even smarter
than Einstein thought it even knows
something about Quantum account Annex
which he never would have guessed oh I
yeah I don't I think that gravity is is
is much smarter than anybody would have
thought
um it's it's really an astonishing
property of you know for classical
Theory to know something about how many
Quantum states there are uh not only in
it you know of its own things like black
holes belong to gravity and so it can
you can figure out how many Quantum
States those have but uh gravity also
leads to something called the
holographic principle which tells you uh
how many Quantum States other things can
have
um and and so no it doesn't tell you in
detail you know all at least so far we
don't know how to do that it doesn't
tell you in detail you know how the
quantum mechanics of various forces
actually works we figured that out in
other ways but it it tells us I mean the
fact that it tells us anything at all
about the quantum properties of matter
and of gravity itself is a total shocker
I mean that's that's a really remarkable
property and I think we haven't
um
taken advantage of it enough and and
right now we're going through a period
where we're figuring out how to how to
really get a lot of mileage out of that
Insight well let's let's uh this is
worth digging into a little bit more so
let's um rewind to the provocative
statement you made about beckenstein and
Hawking telling us how many Quantum
States a black hole had I bet that went
over the heads of some of our audience
members so what exactly did Becca
steinhawking do and what in the world
does it have to do with a number of
quantum States good it I I think maybe
we should talk a little bit about what
Quantum states are in the first place
that would help uh so one way to think
about it is that to go back to
um to the origins of quantum mechanics
people were trying to understand uh
what's called Atomic Spectra that that's
you know if you have a certain kind of
atoms and you shine light at them then
the light that comes out on the other
side is missing some spectral lines you
know how you can break up light using a
prism into white light becomes this sort
of rainbow spectrum of colors
um and so you can you can send white
light through a bunch of of atoms and
depending on what kind of atoms you use
uh what will happen is that these atoms
are going to be very picky they're going
to choose some part of that rainbow
Spectrum they're gonna say I like this
one I like yellow and they're going to
use this yellow to jump up to an excited
state that means that one of the
electrons in the atom is gonna it's
gonna get it's gonna go to a different
Quantum state that has more energy and
then what comes out at the end is the
light that you send in minus the yellow
let's say so you can use this prism to
split up and you're going to see a black
line where that was supposed to be
yellow
um so so that's how people first
discovered this notion of quantum states
that it's basically uh there are
different discrete things that electrons
in an atom can do and you can start
listing them all and those are the
quantum states of the atom and you can
imagine that you know that the
combinations of what electrons and atoms
can do become this you know there's a
lot of different things you can do once
you have more than one atom if you have
a block of iron there's some insane
number of atoms in there and the same
number of electrons and nuclei
correspondingly and those electrons can
be in a lot of different Quantum States
and now you're talking about these sort
of astronomically large numbers that
have to do with how many particles
you've got in there
um and but but but if you ask this
question how many Quantum states does a
block of metal have it's not enough for
me to say that block is you know a meter
by a meter by a meter and it's not
enough for me to tell you how much it
weighs I need to tell you exactly what
that stuff is made of more precisely I
need to tell you what the atoms are that
are in it how they're arranged what the
electrons are able to do I need to talk
about that sort of fundamental tiny
ingredient stuff that is responsible for
these Quantum States and if I don't know
what that is because I've not looked
through a good enough microscope or I
haven't been able to I can indirectly
measure I can try to measure what what
how many Quantum States uh the block of
metal has I could I could go that route
I could try to heat it up a little bit
and depending on how many Quantum States
it has that's going to take more or less
energy so I can figure it out that way
but what beckenstein and Hawking were
able to do now replace that block of
metal by a black hole by the kind of
thing that you get when you collapse
matter under Gravity so strongly that it
just bends space-time in this kind of
hole shape
um you can think of that as an object
and you can ask how many Quantum States
it has but nobody knows what the analog
of atoms are for that right or electrons
and nobody's taken one of these guys and
try to heat it up a little bit to see
how many Quantum States it has by by
checking how much energy does this take
nobody's been able to do that and yet
beckinson and Hawking were able to
calculate how many Quantum States it has
and so that's that's really analogous to
you know being able to figure out how
many Quantum states of block of metal
has without me telling you which metal
it is what what the atoms are and
without me giving one to you so you can
experiment on it and nevertheless you
somehow figured it out it's like whoa
um so that's that's what they were able
to do and
um the the reason that they were able to
do it has a lot to do with the fact that
gravity unlike any other theory that we
know is a theory about the Dynamics of
space and time it's a geometric Theory
and it's the the fact that the geometry
can do interesting things when black
holes are present that effectively
allows them to figure this out and I
think I I'm betting that a lot of
listeners are their their minds are
spinning right now in productive ways
because they've heard me talk about
entropy and they know that entropy is a
way of measuring how many different
microscopic States correspond to a kind
of macroscopic configuration and some of
them will have heard that what
beckenstein Hawking did is calculate the
entropy of a black hole and hopefully
they're going aha that's just what
Raphael just said is that right thanks
for making that connection I should have
said the word entropy but we were going
with a number of ones like those are
basically the same thing up to you know
exponentiation so uh the the larger the
entropy the more Quantum States you're
dealing with but I think this is I mean
the way that you put it is really
wonderful because again most people on
the street have if they've heard of the
word of entropy they're thinking of
cream and coffee mixing into each other
right or you know shuffling cards or
something like that and what you're
pointing out in the quantum world it's
really a way of counting seeing how many
Quantum States go into something and so
that really is a incredibly profound
thing to know about black holes which
we've never done any experiments on
directly yeah that's right now what what
beckenstein and Hawking were able to do
was to calculate what is called the
coarse grain entropy of a black hole
it's basically saying if you know
nothing else about this black hole
except for the fact that it is a black
hole and it has this and that mass and
maybe some it's spinning at some rate
but you just know these sort of very
coarse features
um then you can you can calculate how
many states correspond to that that's
what they were able to do more recently
um we've we figured out a way to
calculate how many Quantum States a
black hole has when I know a lot more
about it
for example I might have formed this
black hole by collapsing matter in a
very specific Quantum State then I know
that initially it it actually doesn't
have a whole lot of different Quantum
States it could be in it can only be in
that one Quantum State now as the black
hole starts evaporating that's another
great thing that that Stephen Hawking
discovered and which I suspect your uh
um your listeners will have will have
heard about from you or others so the
black hole isn't just going to sit there
it's going to start emitting radiation
and it gets smaller and smaller and
smaller and in exchange you get this
growing cloud of radiation that's going
off to far away regions and so the black
hole basically converts itself slowly
into this radiation now if you know that
the black hole is actually in one
specific state that means that later on
the black hole and the radiation
together whatever they became also has
to be in only one possible Quantum State
and that in turn
constrains the entropy that the black
hole has to have by itself the black
hole is now not in one specific Quantum
state if you have a Quantum system
containing two parts in this case a
black hole on the radiation and you're
only asking about one part then even if
they're in one definite State together
that one part will be in an indefinite
State consisting of a list of
possibilities this is something related
to the word entanglement so since we're
throwing out words that your listeners
might have heard you've heard that word
they're entangled and if you look at one
of them they're going to be in what's
called a mixed state lots of different
possibilities and you can you can uh
then use basic principles of quantum
mechanics to say well the black hole
should have a certain amount of entropy
depending on how much of it has
evaporated that entropy goes first up
and then back down as the black hole has
fully evaporated this curve is called
the page curve after Don Page who first
derived it and recently my colleague
Jeff Pennington and a group of people on
the on the East Coast uh well actually
East and West a group of four other
physicists uh simultaneously and
independently discovered a way to derive
this page curve using just gravity uh so
that was a huge breakthrough because
among other things it tells you that the
entropy or the number of possible States
at the end when everything is just
radiation the black hole is gone is one
there's only one possible state that
alone is incredibly important because it
speaks to this long debate that we've
had for almost 50 years about whether or
not black holes return information when
you make a black hole from a definite
State Hawking initially calculated it
radiates into radiation which is in a
mixed state lots of different
possibilities and so you've lost the
information about what that initial
state was you always get the same
garbage out no matter what you put in
what this calculation did was
um to ask gravity in a nice enough way
that you could actually trust the answer
and also do the calculation and gravity
said no no the information is coming
back out and and so this is the the
first time that we've had sort of a
direct gravity calculation check of the
fact that in fact information is not
lost in black holes and it's more
detailed than that because it tells you
exactly how much entropy the black hole
in the radiation have along the way not
just in the beginning and at the end but
during every stage of this evaporation
process
um and it you know you get the answer
that's expected from information comes
out on the nodes and I think let's be
very very uh I'm going to try to be as
careful as I can right now just so
everyone gets this exactly right because
this is very
subtle stuff that is at The Cutting Edge
of modern research and it's easy to sort
of uh simplify it just a bit too much so
we had net engelhardt on the podcast so
she talked her work a little bit she was
one of the four other physics exactly
and uh I guess the way that I think if I
understand it correctly I would say it
is quantum mechanics says that the
information should ultimately be
preserved somewhere we've been having
trouble seeing how that is compatible
with the evaporation of black holes they
haven't told us precisely how the
information gets out in some sense but
they also provided more evidence that it
does in a way that doesn't require too
much specific craziness from String
Theory or extra Dimensions or anything
like that it has yeah it has absolutely
nothing to do with string theory right
so so yeah that calculation is is a
calculation where you you just ask
gravity now here's why it makes sense
for them to have been able to
confirm that information gets out but
not tell us how this because initially
that sounds weird like how does that
make sense how can you confirm the
information comes out but not okay so
nobody is saying that gravity Einstein's
theory as we know it is the final answer
or that some simplistic way of combining
gravity with quantum mechanics uh by
doing what's called a path integral
uh the favorite tool in quantum
mechanics that that's the final answer
and knows everything but it is a much
more powerful approximation scheme than
might have been initially realized it
allows you to ask so it initially asked
allowed Hawking and and beckenstein to
derive the course grain entry of a black
hole that's already pretty sensational
but notice that the entropy or number of
states that's one number it's one number
you're asking just about that one number
and gravity was smart enough to give you
that one number again already surprising
but it's just one number okay now when
you ask
how does the information get out that's
a complicated process when you ask what
is the state that the that the black
hole produces what what exactly state is
that radiation going to be in well
that's having to choose out of some
exorbitant number of possibilities
that's a very very complicated question
that there's good reason to think this
approximation scheme that we're seeing
is quite powerful it's not powerful
powerful enough to do that what what
Jeff Pennington and Neda engelhardt and
her collaborators discovered is that it
is powerful enough to ask and answer the
question you know what is the entropy of
the Hawking radiation as a function of
time when it's emitted by a black hole
that's initially in a definite state
it's again just one number it's a more
sophisticated question than the one that
that Hawking and beckenstein asked but
gravity is smart enough to answer the
question you sort of have to help it
along a little bit you have to use
multiple copies of the space time in
which the black hole is formed and
evaporate and you sort of sew them
together in clever ways and that that
sort of gives a turbo boost to the
smartness of gravity and and it's able
to spit out that answer
but the difficulty of explaining how the
information gets out and in fact in
which precise State the radiation
actually is that looks like it's a it's
a significantly more complex question
and it's not clear that we can ever make
Gravity by itself smart enough to answer
that question so it's not like we're
done we still need to discover a quantum
gravity Theory plenty of work for future
generations of students that's that's
always the message that we have here yes
yeah young people listening we're not
we're not done yet apply for grad school
now exactly uh and to be even a little
bit more specific but again back we're
going to go back and forth from the 70s
to uh 50 years later I think
um it's not just that beckenstein and
Hawking calculated the entropy of black
holes and therefore the number of
quantum States they found that it was
proportional to the area of the Event
Horizon of the black hole and this you
know this is again just one little fact
that maybe okay you know the the Lesser
Minds might say Ah that's fine but we've
been beating our heads against this fact
for a long time and it's led to ideas
like holography and more uh and you
played a major role in clarifying what
holography is really all about how do
you think about how would you tell the
person on the street what physicists
mean by the word holographic or
holographic principle the phrase yeah
um so what it what it means and this
really goes back to what I was saying in
the very beginning about gravity knowing
not only about its own Quantum States
but also about the quantum states of
matter so just now we were discussing
how gravity knows about how many Quantum
States a black hole has that's its own
stuff now let's talk about matter well
um if I could take a bunch of matter
and and compress it and convert it into
a black hole of a certain area
the only way that that's consistent with
the principles of quantum mechanics
which say that information can't be lost
is if the black hole through that list
of quantum states that it could be in
can store the information about which
state the matter was in I could I could
reverse this I could figure it out by
looking somehow carefully enough at what
state the black hole is in ah it was
made from matter in this particular
Quantum State the cat was dead and not
alive or whatever
um in order for that to work
the black hole area in the appropriate
units that beckenstein hockey figured
out so the number of black hole Quantum
States has to be bigger
than the number of quantum States the
matter could have had to start with okay
it's like you know if I have a list of
thousand entries on some piece of paper
and I give you a form with with with
only 10 entries you can't you can't
transfer them all you know that you're
going to be too squeeze so if I give you
a longer list there's no problem I mean
a longer form but but if it's any any
shorter than a thousand entries you
can't transfer it you can't transfer the
information entropy has to go up so
there has to be enough room in the black
hole yeah exactly there has to be enough
room in the black hole and now what's
interesting about this this thought
experiment that we just did
is that all I said was well suppose I
converted this matter into a black hole
of a certain area I didn't tell you
anything else about what that matter was
I didn't even have to know what the you
know Elementary particles are that that
the world is made out of I could be
totally ignorant of that it would still
have to be true
um so you can sort of Glimpse maybe from
this argument that we can leverage this
knowledge about how many states a black
hole has to to make very Universal
statements about how much information
there is in matter that fits into a
certain region if it doesn't fit in that
region you probably couldn't make a
black hole out of it yeah you had to be
able to compress it to make a black hole
now this sounds very vague but we so the
my contribution to this subject was to
turn that into a very precise statement
I can start with any surface in any
space time and I can look at its area
and I can use that to constrain how many
Quantum States how complicated the world
can be in in a very precisely defined
neighborhood of that surface roughly
it's inside okay it's not always the
Insight in the way that you might think
about it but it's it's roughly that it
has to do with what light rates do that
come out of that surface yeah
um and so for example an example of that
is I could ask about the information
content of the universe right now by
which I mean the part of the universe
that we can see which is only as far as
you know the universe is 13 or 14
billion years old and lights only had so
much time to reach us so there's there's
a certain part of the universe that we
can see and what my prescription tells
you is how much information there could
possibly be in that in that part of the
universe and it tells you that in terms
of the largest area on what's called our
past light cone so if you if you ask you
know what is the the surface that the
light rays traced out that are reaching
us just now and that started out the Big
Bang
that has a larger sphere somewhere along
the way and its area
tells you that the Universe has an
entropy that's no more than 10 to 120 or
something like that uh so that's that's
an example of the holographic principle
at work and it's surprising right it's
surprising uh not only because it's
again weird that gravity knows something
about the quantum states of matter
um it's completely Universal it doesn't
matter that matter is made out of
electrons or protons or you know maybe
fundamentally it's strings the statement
is just true but also it's surprising
because you would have thought that the
amount of information you can have in a
region should grow like the volume not
like the area more if I if I make a you
know if I have a heap of of computer
chips that each store a gigabyte of data
or something then you know the volume of
the Heap tells me how much information
is stored not the area of its surface or
something
so that's that's another surprising
feature and that's why it's called the
holographic principle it's it's a bit
like you know the information is stored
on the on the boundary or on some
surfaces and also just a very simple
fact that it's a finite number there's a
finite number of bits of information
which yes you would not have guessed
from any non-gravitational Quantum field
Theory gravity is again being special
yeah that's right and that's really one
way of a very nice way of thinking about
it is to just start by forgetting
gravity completely then as you say our
our most fundamental theories tell us
that there's there's no limit at all on
how much information you can store in
any region of space-time because you can
always go to smaller distances yeah in
in principle not in practice right now
but there's no there's no wall you hit
you can it there's no there's nothing
that tells you that it's not in
principle possible when you turn on
gravity the first naive guess you might
have is that the maximum information
content should grow like the volume you
might think that gravity gives you a
sort of shortest distance scale that it
makes sense to think about and so you
can sort of divide your region up into
tiny little cubes of that size and count
them and yeah the plank length and then
you'd think okay if I if I double the
volume I've doubled the amount of
information I can store but that would
still be wrong and the reason that it's
wrong is that it's too easy to to change
the shape of space-time dramatically
before you even have a chance to make
use of these tiny distances it's too
easy to for example make a black hole I
know it's in practice pretty hard to
make a black hole for us in a lab we
don't know how to do it but
um compared to accessing all these
would-be
um tiny regions in which we can store
information it's actually much easier to
make a black hole and that's what
happens first and so you're thwarted in
your attempt to store a volumes worth of
information in your region and and you
just ended up making a black hole and
that that that that that information
content is now set by its surface area
and this leads to something that is a
little bit both provocative and vague
and maybe those two things are are
helping each other out but it's a kind
of non-locality that uh is special to
gravity you know Quantum field theory of
the standard model particle physics or
whatever is a quintessentially local
Theory there's a wave a field value at
every point in space classically and you
quantize it and of course there's
entanglement but still particles bump
into each other at the same point in
space but the holographic bound or the
earlier beckenstein bound and whatever
how much energy or information you can
fit in a region that's not a statement
about what happens at a point it's a
statement about what happens in a region
and that's a different kind of physics
in some deep way that's right
um gravity is telling us that the world
is in some in some deep way non-local
that it's not you know so so an
important principle of physics
ironically it's sort of encoded in what
Einstein first discovered when he
formulated special relativity is this
idea of locality that if I have
something going on uh at the Andromeda
let's say there that's some some star
explodes in the Andromeda galaxy right
now uh well I can't find out about that
faster than the amount of time that it
takes light to travel from Andromeda to
here uh I'm gonna have to wait I can't
learn about this instantaneously in fact
it it doesn't even that notion isn't
even very well defined
um so that's been a very important
principle in physics and yet the
holographic principle tells us that at
some level it has to be wrong right if I
if I can store all of the information
about some space-time region on its
boundary uh well that means that I in
some sense I should be able to look
at this boundary and and read of
information about what's going on
instantaneously some distance away from
it in the interior and in fact that it's
literally what we're able to do when we
apply this adsc FD correspondence the
adcft correspondence that I mentioned
this explicit quantum theory of gravity
that we have for some class of space
times is it realizes this notion of the
holographic principle in a in a totally
explicit way again you can put it on
computer and do calculations and and you
have the ability on the boundary of the
space time to act with what's called a
quantum mechanical operator like a thing
that changes stuff in such a way that
instantaneously in some sense it changes
the state from let's say the universe is
empty to the universe has an elephant in
the center and now the reason that
that's not a complete contradiction with
what Einstein was was established 100
years earlier
um is that in in fact
it is still inconsistent for an elephant
to suddenly appear in the center of the
space-time
that's not the correct interpretation of
what we're doing when we're acting with
that elephant creation operator
um the there is in fact no consistent
way of thinking about this as space and
time and the way we like to classically
think about it for a while what what is
really happening is that we've destroyed
the universe and we've recreated it with
an elephant in it and I think we're
beginning to see glimpses again thanks
to this recent progress
um of how this kind of thing might play
out more generally so I was complaining
over and over that this ads cfd
corresponds is about universities that
are not like ours as wonderful as it is
it's not like our universe what we want
to do is be able to describe our own
universe and in fact Jeff Pennington and
I just had a paper out in which we're
trying to take a step towards being able
to do that we're we're trying to say
that if you have access to a particular
part of space-time you don't have to
literally be all the way on the boundary
it's not even clear what that means in
the real world in the real world we're
part of the space type so we want to be
able to say to ask what can we do that's
in some sense non-local that's analogous
to this elephant creation operator if we
control some part of the space-time but
maybe not all of it there's some part
that's far away where we want to make
the elephant and and we were able to
give a rule for not exactly how that
should work but for how far away you can
make an elephant uh if you have control
over a certain you know region of your
universe and
um and hopefully you know by studying
that pattern we can learn more about how
quantum gravity actually works in more
realistic uh situations like our own
universe and this is sorry I should ask
is that work that you just talked about
with Jeff Pennington in the context of
ads EFT well so no I mean it's it's
motivated by some things that we learned
thanks to adscfd and thanks to string
theory
um but it is logically independent of
that I mean what what was a nice check
is that when you apply our more general
rule to this ads setting where we
already knew how things work it gives us
back those things that we knew how they
worked it it it it doesn't contradict
what we had before but the whole point
here is to allow it to be applied in in
a universe like our own or really any
any Universe you can dream up you've
told us uh correctly that ads which
stands for anti-decider space is not our
universe but we haven't actually told
the audience what it is so maybe we can
take a take a breath here and and try to
explain what ads is and why it is an
implementation of the holographic
principle in such a nice way ah yes well
I'm sure you're Highly Educated
listeners will have heard this before so
I hope I'm not I'm not uh going to
create too much overlap but there our
our universe is is sort of more and more
rapidly expanding it has something
called a positive cosmological constant
um the thing I said earlier about String
Theory being a cool theory is that it
can explain why it's so small
that's actually a mystery uh but one fun
fact about it is that it is positive if
it were negative we'd be a little closer
to something called anti-disitter space
we'd still not be an anti-disitter space
because it looks like we have a sort of
infinite amount of matter distributed
all over the place as far as we can see
so that would still not quite get us
there but if you removed most of that
matter and you had this negative version
of this cosmological constant then you'd
be an anti-disitter space and
antidisitter space is a funny place if
you were sitting in it and you throw
your friend away from you because you
don't like him anymore your friend is
going to come flying back to you a
little while later how long that depends
on how large this negative cosmological
constant is and is it going to oscillate
back and forth like this the whole time
and you'll never get rid of him uh
consider where we live it's the opposite
if I if I'm tired of my friend and I
just put him out in space to float away
from me he's gonna fly faster and faster
away from me and eventually we gone
title this is why I have no friends
are a little uh you know extremist a
little bit you know making elephants
throwing away your friends come on yeah
so but what what this what this
effectively means is that anti-decider
space is kind of like a box you're
closed it in a box it's a little bit
weird because it is spatially infinite
but no matter how how hard you throw
away your ex-friend they're gonna come
back to you
um so you'll always have friends in
anti-sitter space and it being a box
helps with this holographic stuff yeah
sorry just to say it again so I think
we're on the same page uh you're
throwing away your friends I mean some
of us would have just chosen baseballs
but okay you're throwing away your
friends uh the harder you throw them the
further away they get because space is
infinitely big but they will still
always come back that's the point yeah
and in fact the time that they that it
takes for them to come back won't depend
on how how far away I throw them they
uh they get turned around uh it's a bit
like a pendulum yeah you know how the
how the
um the frequency of a pendulum doesn't
depend on the amplitude uh which is why
Galileo used them as clocks uh it's it's
a very very useful analogy I think it's
it's just like that except it actually
works even better than for a pendulum if
you if you move a pendulum too far out
then actually you start seeing that it's
no longer true but in anti-disitter
space this is just exactly true uh your
friend is like it's like a pendulum with
a fixed frequency
anyway
um friends aside uh and I decided it's
kind of like a box and you can think of
the Hologram as being on the boundary of
the Box the Hologram is our quantum
gravity Theory which in some non-local
way
um encodes what's going on in the
interior of the Box
um and and that that theory which is
just a standard completely well
understood Theory called conformal field
Theory
um that's the CFT in the name ads CFT
correspondence that theory is our
complete quantum gravity theory for that
type of boxy universe and it and the
it's sort of the Inside Out version
almost of the black hole where we're
standing outside and is it is it
accurate in the black hole case I mean
how how accurate is it to say from the
holographic point of view that the
information about the black hole
literally is there on the horizon versus
just equal an amount to the area of the
Horizon that's that's a loaded question
to which to which I don't I mean I think
it's also not a settled question
um the the reason that it's a loaded
question is that first of all it's it's
certainly from the Viewpoint of somebody
who sees the black hole form stays far
away comfortable safe and the black hole
starts evaporating this radiation is
coming out it is perfectly consistent
with any experiment that they can do to
say that the black hole is literally a
membrane that stores an amount of
information equal to its surface area
and they'll never have to think about
what's going on inside the black hole it
never matters to for anything that they
want to explain because they're not
going there
and everything that they can observe can
be completely explained by this picture
where the world basically ends on the
horizon of the black hole The Horizon of
a black hole is a Surface in the
simplest case spherical that you had
better not cross if you ever want to get
back out to distant regions it's it's
the one that if you cross you're going
to get crunched eventually and hit some
kind of Singularity now suppose you are
that person who's gonna fly a crayon
You're The Adventurous type who's going
to fly across the Horizon and find out
what the interior looks like well
there's a real contradiction between
what I just said the outside Observer
can do think about the black hole as a
as an object the world ending on that
membrane and you're trying to fly right
through the Horizon and see nothing
special there and enter the interior
Einstein's theory tells you that there
is nothing special there Einstein's
theory general relativity our theory of
gravity very well tested is absolutely
insistent that crossing the Horizon of
black hole is like empty space
everywhere like any other kind of empty
space there's not a sign saying here's
the Horizon there's not a slap you get
when you uh you know it's not even like
hitting a fly on a freeway uh
splattering on your LGL it should be
nothing you should not be able to notice
it we should be able to cross the
Horizon of a very large black hole right
now without knowing about it and those
two principles are in in a serious
conflict with one another I suspect you
may have discussed this before it's
called the in in its old form it's
called the black hole information
Paradox what I said earlier about the
outside Observer is predicated on the
idea that information comes out of the
black hole
um in that case it seems necessary to
say that that information while the
black hole is still there is sort of
stored on its Horizon and so it is sort
of what you want to be true if you care
a lot about quantum mechanics and then
the other perspective where you fall in
you want to see nothing special at the
Horizon that's what you want to be true
if you care about gravity if you care
about Einstein and uh you know real
physicists care about both and so
they're like oh my God what am I going
to do now because these two things don't
fit together at all and the modern
incarnation of that is called the
firewall Paradox it's just really a
sharper strengthened version of of the
argument that led Hawking to conclude
that black holes don't return it for me
so Hawking came down on the side of the
in-falling Observer of the Gravity Guy
yeah
um and and uh today I think the evidence
is overwhelming that the information
does come out so you are likely to take
the point of view of the outside
Observer who sees the information coming
out but then you see seem to be forced
to say that there's some kind of
structure at the Horizon in conflict
with gravity some kind of firewall or
whatever you want to call it so we're
still grappling with that well we did
have uh Lenny suskind on the podcast so
we talked a little bit about
complementarity and wouldn't he if he
were here say both perspectives are
correct to The in-falling Observer you
see nothing and the outside one it looks
like a membrane of the horizon
yeah I I would say uh well let me
certainly it you know is an advocate of
a particular approach to resolving this
problem
um which which I also uh tried initially
after this this firewall paper appeared
um and I think we
um we we both you know would probably
agree that it's worth exploring
approaches of this of this type I think
we would have different levels of
confidence that uh that they solve the
problem uh so in particular my my sense
is that right now there is no resolution
of this Paradox that that fully
preserves both of these fundamental
principles uh that doesn't in some way
violate important aspects of quantum
mechanics and ore of gravity uh the
approaches that I like the least are the
ones that violate both
um because you know if as I think one
thing we learned from Einstein and and
and and some of his predecessors in in
the history of physics is when when you
have two deep principles that turn out
to be in conflict with each other
um that's that's definitely a huge
opportunity for progress I mean in
physics we like crises right because
it's it's it it sharpens things and it
gets it tells us okay here's what we
have to dig but but you want to come
down on one or the other side
uh you don't want to violate both
because that's that's really ugly you
know it it it doesn't seem likely to me
that quantum mechanics is a little bit
wrong and gravity is a little bit wrong
I'd rather have one of them be really
wrong and and understand how to move
forward uh and preserve the other so my
feeling is that that a lot of the
approaches that we're seeing today kind
of break both a little bit I think for
example Lenny would concede that black
holes in fact can have firewalls
um he's just trying to save us from
having firewalls when the black hole has
maybe freshly formed and it's not yet
insanely old and and you know to me
that's like who cares like once you can
have firewalls it's just a terrible
affront to general relativity right and
I don't really to me it makes very
little difference when that happens to
me it seems like either we get rid of
them or if we can then you know let's
try to understand the problem in a
different way
um let's try to understand where they
come from which we don't I mean if
firewalls form we have absolutely no
idea what the dynamic dynamics of that
is so I'm not saying that I know how to
answer this problem but I think a crisis
is a great opportunity and we should be
careful not to think that we've solved
it I think we haven't okay they're very
very good to hear we're very very
interesting to hear and maybe be nice to
have solved it but we take what we can
get and like you say the crises are
opportunities in this field so that that
is a good thing
um but I guess the feeling I'm getting
then is
um there is this relationship between
I want to say space-time and reality but
maybe that's a pregnant way of putting
it
um there's this question of what exists
and how we should think about the world
and I think it's very natural for most
people to think of space and stuff in it
as existing and in some sense this idea
the holographic principle for black
holes where you can think of them as
having all the information on the
horizon but maybe there's an interior if
you jump in and also the ads CMT version
which is sort of the Inside Out version
where we're inside the Horizon and it's
infinitely far away and there's all of
our information is there both of these
are undermining the idea that there is
stuff located at points in space right
quantum mechanics or quantum gravity
seems to be a bit more subtle than that
if the adse CFT correspondence is saying
there's two totally different ways of
talking which in those two ways of
talking put stuff and space on very
different footings
yeah I I agree with everything you've
said but I I don't think that this in
itself is is very shocking or unusual I
mean I think that the the history of
physics is a story of how we have found
new Concepts that allow us to think
about phenomena on a deeper level
um but that doesn't mean that what we
had before was wrong nor does it mean
that the New Concept is the final word
and that's how somehow things really are
right I I
I mean it seems pretty obvious to me
that this debate about what's real I
mean to me anyway it's completely
meaningless what we can ask about is
what are efficient ways of describing
nature what are yeah what are economical
ways of explaining the data that we have
of explaining experiments we can do and
um that's that's what changes over time
so you know a good example is is is
let's say the motion of the planets
right uh so already in ancient times
there was a pretty good theory of that
um uh by by Ptolemy and and it you know
it it was it was pretty complicated but
it kind of did the job uh reasonably
well
um allowed you to predict where they
were going to be the next day it's a
pretty big success
um and you know so we could say okay but
but these these drawings that he made
with you know the the the sun first
going around the planets and then you
know they're going to be these epicycles
and that ex that was obviously very
complicated it would have been much
easier if you just put the sun in the
center
and and let the planets go around it and
you know it it would have been uh more
to our liking we know today that that's
the more efficient way of thinking about
it but it wasn't really wrong it wasn't
wrong because you're perfectly free to
take the point of view that you're in
the middle of the world and the Sun is
going around you and then the other
planets are going around the sun while
the Sun is going around you that doesn't
give you the wrong answer that's
actually what we see in the sky right
like I can see the headlines now
Berkeley Professor comes out Centric
view of the cosmos all right
sorry that that train left a long time
ago I mean you know this is just a
question of what's more economical it's
not a question of what's right or wrong
you can certainly describe the world in
that in that convoluted way it's just
it's kind of painful tedious and more
importantly it makes it harder to make
progress after that right it was it was
a lot harder you know to understand you
know for example I don't think Newton
could have gone on from Ptolemy to his
Force law that tells you why the planets
move like that around the sun right but
once you had Kepler first of all the
refinement that it's not just circles
but ellipses and and then you know yeah
the sun in the center it's much easier
to figure out like okay what do I have
to put in you know to sort of to reverse
engineer like the force that is making
the planets do that thing it's much
easier once you have a simple picture of
what's happening and that's why that was
so vital it's vital for Progress that
you think about it in a simple way and
not in a convoluted
um but you know what was was Kepler
wrong uh once once Einstein discovered
how that the planets actually you know
don't quite move on these ellipses
because yeah in some sense he was wrong
but it was you know it was a better
explanation and simpler and it it you
know it it was yeah with fewer
ingredients explain more data
um so so that's that's always the
progress and I don't think that the
status of general relativity is any
different fundamentally from the status
of Ptolemy or of Kepler uh it's just
more powerful it it explains a lot more
things with with fewer ingredients uh
and it's still alive it's been tested
over and over most dramatically recently
by by the discovery of gravitational
radiation from black hole mergers and
other compact objects merging
um it's fantastically successful Theory
but I think in physics we never ask is
this real we can ask you know what's
better
I'm perfectly happy to ask what's real I
think that's what I'm very interested in
doing but otherwise I I do very much
appreciate the you know operationalizing
and simplifying like what what gets us
understanding but let me ask almost the
same question but in a slightly more
down-to-earth way uh which is more
sympathetic to the philosophy you just
put forward the adsc of T correspondence
uh which as you've correctly said is not
our world we live in a different world
than the anti-decider world but
nevertheless it it posits an equipment
equivalence between a description that
has you know a certain number of
dimensions of space time with an
anti-decider kind of universe and one
fewer dimensions of space-time at the
boundary with no gravity at all so my
question is if that were the universe
right if we really did live in ads CFT
would we live in ads or would we live in
CFT you would see a Universe with
gravity and anti-decenter space or would
we see a Universe with no gravity in one
fewer Dimensions or could there be both
or is that even a sensible question I
think it is a sensible question and what
I was trying to say I guess I didn't
really close the deal in what I said
earlier what I was trying to say is that
that question is exactly analogous to
asking is gravity a force that keeps the
planets going around the Sun or is
Gravity the curvature of space-time and
the planets are just trying to go away
as straight as possible in this curved
space time well
for most purposes those are
mathematically equivalent statements now
if you want extremely accurate
descriptions of the Motions of some of
the planets like that of mercury over
100 years then in fact turns out that
one of them is gives you the correct
answer and the other one is just a
little bit raw so one is a better
approximation than the other so what's
interesting right is that at the
quantitative level of explaining
experiments at least as far as the solar
system is concerned there's almost no
difference between these two
descriptions but from the conceptual
Viewpoint they couldn't be more
different it's surprising that it's
possible for to even be remotely similar
in any kind of situation in terms of
outcomes but they are and so in in those
settings where they give you the same
answer to you know as good an
approximation as you need I I don't you
know you can go back and forth between
both the scripts that's just equally
good it's up to you which one you like
better okay now I think now you're
you're uh dodging a little bit too
quickly here because even if yes I know
that even if ads and the CFT
correspondence uh the two sides are
equally formally good you notice what
like most of us who most of my friends
think they live in a three-dimensional
space
I don't know of anyone who goes oh yeah
I live in the two-dimensional
holographic duel to your space like
there there's something that is closer
to the Manifest image of the world and
is yeah it's usually the worst Theory
right I mean yeah I mean if you if you
went by what we think is true uh you
know based on everyday experience there
also wouldn't be any quantum mechanics
and that you know the speed of light
wouldn't be the limit because why on
Earth should that be true and you know I
I don't know there shouldn't be a twin
paradox there that lots of things are
not like what we experience in every day
I don't think that has anything to do
with question you ask me
there's two different descriptions that
have different numbers of dimensions of
space yeah surely if there were living
creatures in that Universe they would
hit upon one of those answers before the
other one oh I'm sure they would well
okay one of those that's that's the same
as for us right we've already hit upon
classical gravity
the world that's the easy description
that you discover first probably I don't
know maybe they're very different from
us they're brainspired differently but
um yeah I would expect that
APS CFT creatures would probably first
find themselves on the ads side where
there was gravity rather than on the
conformal field theory side where there
was not gravity we can we can simplify
this discussion by pretending for a
moment that we actually did live in an
asymptotically anti-deciderate Universe
sorry that was very technical we live in
one of these yep boxy ads universes
because you know you could put our
galaxy there
and just don't put any of the other
stuff and it would have made absolutely
no difference for the evolution of
humans and everything would have
happened exactly the same way and we
will be sitting here right now and maybe
we haven't measured yet what the
universe looks like you know we're kind
of slow that way and we're gonna build
our first telescope tomorrow and we're
going to discover oh It's ADS but you
know at that point we would be in
precisely the situation we have a good
theory of gravity Einstein's theory
we've discovered Quantum me guys we want
to put them together
and
um maybe we've already discovered the
adsc FD correspondence so we even have a
good quantum theory of gravity and now
we look at our universe and we discover
oh it's anti-deciliary space Bingo we
got super lucky we live in that Universe
for which we already have a point of
gravity Theory wouldn't that be nice
okay I think that uh you're begging an
important question here but I'm going to
table it until the next time we're on
the same coast and uh I can get you beer
and or coffee and we can Hammer this one
out because I do want to switch gears as
we as we wind up
um back to the real world where we do
live where we have a positive
cosmological constant and one of the
things that modern theoretical physics
has to Grapple with is this fact that we
know so much about the counterfactual
case with the negative cosmological
constitution adsc of T and we would like
to know more about the real world and we
seem to be struggling with that do you
have uh strong opinions or do you have a
way of phrasing why it seems to be so
hard to do the analogous thing for the
real world I I guess nature doesn't like
to throw softballs
um it it's it's a really challenging
situation because for the problem isn't
just that we don't have a good quantum
gravity theory for our own Universe the
problem is worse because it's not
totally clear what we would want that
theory to compute for us uh in in many
situations like in adcft
um it's possible to Define sort of
idealized exact observables that exist
somewhere in the universe maybe not
they're not accessible maybe to to you
know humans with their finite resources
but at least in principle it's it's you
can imagine that you could always
increase your resources and do better
and better and and approach this
idealized kind of measurement
um uh as well as as you desire
and in our universe it's not clear
whether such a thing exists and what it
would be uh so it's not totally clear
what exactly we're aiming at and that
has something to do with the fact that
anti-decider space is like a box it has
a boundary and the boundary is a good
place to go if you want to make things
exact there's a lot of space there and
and you can you can build very precise
uh machines and and do very precise
measurements
um and in our you know our universe is
not all like that so that's one thing
that um
uh really makes this challenge hard
um but another thing which is just my
personal opinion I guess is that it's
extremely unlikely that our universe is
fundamentally of the type where you have
a positive cosmological constant forever
okay so
um I mean that's a pretty strong
statement you just made given the lack
of empirical knowledge about it yeah so
so one one uh one reason there are two
reasons why I believe that
um one is a proposal that Joe polchinski
and I made some some 20 years ago uh
about what explains the small positive
value of our of The observed
cosmological constant and that is in my
view currently the only viable
explanation of that value and in that
explanation it is the case that there
are many other possible values that the
cosmological constant can take
it's just that we're stuck with one for
a while sort of like the way that you
can have a radioactive atom and it sits
around for a billion years and then it
decays into a different atom these time
scales can be very large you can you can
think there's nothing else in the world
but but in fact there is in one day our
universe will Decay to uh to one with it
with us with a smaller cosmological
constant and and there is an enormous
fundamental difference even if that
takes a very long time to happen there's
an enormous fundamental difference in
what you might think a quantum gravity
Theory should look like depending on
whether or not that happens
um the second reason why I think that
will happen is is
um a different observational reason
um maybe a little bit more direct
which is actually an argument that Lenny
suskin made uh some time around and his
collaborators claibon and Dyson around
2002 or three something like that uh
data said well suppose that we do live
eternally in this kind of universe
forever
well that kind of universe turns into a
box as well
but it's different from the anti-decider
box it's it's called a decider box
amazingly uh and this the sitter space
is a warm box it's walls unlike those of
of anti-disitter space have some fixed
temperature that never goes quite to
zero and when you have a warm box
one of the weirdnesses of quantum
mechanics is that everything that it can
eventually produce as as sort of thermal
radiation as sort of temperature garbage
that gets sent into you know along your
way will eventually be produced it might
take a long time
but but uh but it's going to happen and
in fact if that box exists for an
infinite amount of time everything is
going to happen infinitely many times
and that isn't just confusing but in in
a way that I think they argued very
nicely uh it's inconsistent with our
observations or more precisely in a
theory that posits that our cosmological
constant is never going to go away
what we observe has unbelievably small
probability precisely the sort of
situation that would normally cause you
to reject a theory you know you've done
some experiment you got some data that
data shouldn't have happened according
to that theory
so you Chuck it out and find a better
one so that's that's reason number two
why I don't think we will forever be
stuck with this positive cosmological
constant and of course I think it's
significant that those reasons we put
both point in the same direction they're
consistent basically the boltzmann
bearing problem as my yep that is
sometimes called the boltzmann break
problem okay so I I like to call it an
inconsistent consistency between Theory
and observation so you can reject the
theory and bite my tongue so hard
because there's so many things I want to
say but look I know I know you suffer
I'm just gonna indulge myself for the
for the next
uh just I do want to sort of wrap it all
up because it really you know we're
right close to something that I think is
crucially important here
um in that as you already said very
nicely
um the center space the universe with a
positive cosmological constant becomes
like a box there's a horizon around us
uh eventually you know all the galaxies
float away and you enter empty space the
difference with anti-decider space being
that the box has a finite size right the
The Horizon has a finite area around us
and so one of the technical difficulties
in doing in decider what we know how to
do an anti-decider is that the boundary
where our information lives
holographically is not infinitely big
into sitter space right it's it has a
finite size and Quantum field theories
naturally have an infinite number of
degrees of freedom or even if we want to
go to super technical language and
infinite dimensional Hilbert space
whereas the descenter box that we will
eventually go to has a finite entropy a
finite number of quantum degrees of
freedom and then I asked you before
should we think about you know the
Horizon of a black hole as really being
everything that's on it so if that's our
future if our future is we empty out and
we have a horizon around us with a
finite number of degrees of freedom we
have a finite entropy does that mean
which I think maybe the Dyson cleven and
suskin Analysis thought of that really
the whole Theory of Everything only has
a finite number of degrees of freedom a
finite number of quantum States yeah
that's a great question
I mean this is why I thought this paper
was so important I you know the reason
so I think this was a very important
question you know can it be that our
universe is sort of the final word as
far as this value of the cosmological
constant is concerned and therefore the
the number of states
in in in whatever fundamental quantum
theory describes it there was a a very
nice argument that was made by fischler
and and and Banks uh
uh in I think in the around 2000
um that maybe that's the kind of quantum
gravity we should be looking for right
one where there's only a finite number
of states so very different from the
kind of things that you were just saying
you know Quantum field theory always has
infinitely made no matter what uh what
the setting is unless you put some
explicit sort of discretization
and when when Joe and I discovered what
later was called the landscape of string
theory this this our our way of solving
the cosmological constant problem that
was
a proposal that you know in some aspect
of which I think troubled a lot of
people and which certainly regarded as
quite radical
and you know as a physicist I mean I
think you're always supposed to start by
trying to shoot down your own ideas so I
spent the next two or three years
um basically pursuing this idea that
that fischler and Banks had proposed uh
that you know maybe the world works this
completely other way where you know we
have we have a finite number of states
and it is what it is because it's trying
to make do with this finite number of
states and it you know it it seemed like
definitely you know I I've seen a lot of
worse ideas than that and and so it
seemed like it was worth thinking about
it and it was only this argument of of
uh Dyson klebon and suskin that that
theory is necessarily inconsistent or at
least I I was compelled by this argument
I thought it was convincing enough that
it's inconsistent with observation uh
and and that at that point I guess I
embraced the landscape and moved on
so it so therefore you would say you're
happiest with the idea that there are an
infinite number of possible Quantum
States in in the universe an infant
dimensional helper space I don't think
um I guess this is one of those
differences between necessary and
sufficient right so if Tom Tom Banks and
Willie fishler's idea was to sort of
start with the idea that the Hilbert
space the number of possible Quantum
States is finite and then say well maybe
it's just that right number that gives
us a universe like ours and it couldn't
have been any other way because for some
fundamental reason we're yet to discover
you just handed this finite Hilbert
space
um and then you know I I think that this
argument that this is inconsistent with
observation tells us that that's not
quite how it works
um
it
but once you're sort of outside of the
confines of that particular way of
thinking about the problem I think it
becomes more difficult to say exactly
what should replace it I mean I if you
put a gun to my head I would say yeah to
the extent that a quantum gravity Theory
is going to be just described in terms
of standard quantum mechanics which I
don't think is a completely settled
question
um with a you know Hilbert space that's
associated with it my guess would be
that that's an infinite dimension of
Hubert space uh but but now we're on a
much less constrained territory where
it's it's harder to be sure about how it
plays out I would say I don't know if
you're going to make it very far in
physics with this sort of uh humble
attitude that you know there are some
questions you don't know the answer to
you gotta
give people the impression there's still
questions that we need to work on I
don't know how you know how are we going
to get PR like this uh well yeah if if
we knew the answer to all questions I'd
be out of a job so oh no wait I have 10
here yeah yeah no we figured it all out
we'll figure it out no I think you got a
very very good job of helping us
understand uh how much progress we've
made but also how much there remains to
be figured out and uh and I have been
biting my tongue but we have more things
to talk about I think uh offline I hope
that the the audience gets a lot out of
this so Raphael buso thanks very much
for being on the mindscape podcast
thanks for having me
[Music]
la la la la la
[Music]